welcome to today's live broadcast titled
experimental design and the
reproducibility crisis
pitfalls power and practical best
practice
it will be co-presented by associated
associate professors dr joe garner and
dr brianna gaskell
my name is megan lafollette and i am the
3rs fellow for the north american 3rs
collaborator
collaborative and i'll be your moderator
today today's seminar is brought to you
by lab roots the new jersey association
for biomedical research
the national center for 3rs and the
north american 3rs collaborative
thinkers and sponsors for more
information please visit them on their
websites
i would like to remind everyone
is anticipate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time during
the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question
box and click on the send button also
please notice that you can share this
webinar
on your personal social media just click
on the social sharing tab to let your
friends and colleagues know about
today's live event
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation just click on the
support tab at the far
top right of your presentation window or
report your problem
via the ask a question box i'd also like
to note that
today's presentation offers continuing
education
credits please click on the continuing
education credits
tab located at the top right of the
presentation window
to obtain those credits now i'd like to
introduce
our presenters today first we'll be
hearing from dr joe garner
he's an associate professor of
comparative medicine at stanford
university
and he leads stanford's technique
refinement and innovation labs
further he has interests in abnormal
behaviors in animals and humans and the
scientific
impact of welfare problems in the
laboratory animals
professor of animal welfare at purdue
university she leads purdue
purdue's laboratory animal welfare
research group and has
specific interests in animal welfare
assessment
rodent well-being and elucidating the
scientific impact of welfare problems
and animal-based
research for a complete biography on dr
garner and dr gaskell
please visit the biography tab at the
top of your screen
dr garner you may now begin your
presentation
thank you thank you
megan thank you everybody for being here
it's a real pleasure to be here with you
today
um
so i always like to start uh just with
some disclosures
and conflicts of interest i serve on the
scientific advisory board for a number
of organizations
including the tlc foundation for body
focused regressive behaviors
beautiful you mrkh foundation i've
previously served on the
uh advisory board for tourette syndrome
of america
i consult a variety of different um
companies and organizations
and um i have donors both from industry
and and from private philanthropy uh
none of
these disclosures are conflicts for
today's presentation
so with that i'd just like to thank you
all for being here again
and uh let's jump into it
so i think if you are here today um in
some way or other you care about
statistics
so what is that do you care because good
experimental design is just the right
thing to do
do you care because i cooks would like
better
number justifications i think we would
all love to see that
do you care because you have some idea
that statistics maybe could reduce
animal use or otherwise improve the
three arts
are you here because you care about the
ethics of animal use
are you here because science is meant to
be reproducible and maybe you have
suspicion that
there may be an issue there are you here
because
we'd like to improve translation to
human outcomes again i think
um that is something that we would all
very much like to achieve especially in
the current environment
are you here because efficient designs
mean quicker drug development
again something i think that is very
personal today
and are you here because you care about
public health
well in fact all of these i think are
just different sides of the same issue
i think if you care about any one of
these things in fact you care about all
of them
even if that might not be immediately
obvious
and statistics and experimental design
is the the
lowest hanging fruit to address many of
these issues why would i say that
what i'd like to do for the next few
minutes is work through the chance that
a basic discovery or a basic
um animal project will result in a human
drug
so first of all we are in what is
commonly referred to as a
reproducibility crisis
in in biomedical science right now and
there's now a number of different
um data sets that show us that when you
formally attempt to
replicate any given basic research
finding in pre-medical work
then you have somewhere between a 10
and a 50 chance of being able to do that
in other words generally speaking the
majority
of pre-clinical research is not
reproducible in another laboratory
and um friedman and colleagues try to
estimate the cost of that
uh to just uh just
the the us academic effort and
so we think there's probably about it or
not we they think
that there's probably about a 28 billion
dollar a year cost to the u.s research
effort
just from the non-reproducibility of
experiments
and obviously if we could fix this
problem to at least some degree
it would benefit everybody enormously
so let's suppose that we've um
we've found a a good
lead and we've been able to reproduce it
and our drug companies taking it up
and they've been able to reproduce that
basic work in in-house
and they begin to take the the compound
through the pipeline
well actually only roughly 35 of
compounds entering the pipeline
make it to human trials and this is
generally due to
um to issues around lead optimization
industrial chemistry uh prepaid called
toxicology things like that
um that
is probably something that is a pretty
fixed number
um and so the real question then is
what is the chance the basic uh
discovery once it gets into human trials
is actually going to make it to market
and again there's a number of data sets
looking at this
and um this work which came from color
and landis in 2004
uh would suggest that on average it's
roughly one in nine compounds actually
make it through
to uh to market and there's a great
disparity between different
uh fields of discovery uh in that number
um and if anything these numbers have
gotten worse
since 2004. uh
so when you um
when you dig down into this we see
somewhere between three percent and 20
of drugs um we'll make it through
depending on
indication um it's very interesting that
cardiovascular drugs are actually the
best performing class
um you will also be relieved to know in
more recent data sets
that um vaccines are also an extremely
well-performing class
of compounds or interventions
so again when you dig into these data
sets and there's american data sets as
european data sets
you see that somewhere between 20 to 50
percent of these failures are due to
human toxicology
or other non-animal related sources of
failure
um in a clinical trials in human trials
in other words somewhere between eighty
percent and fifty percent of these
failures
are because the drugs uh the drug under
consideration
either doesn't work or doesn't work well
enough um
to move forward and again in
in other words that means that
somewhere between 50 and 80 um of
these compounds which seem to work in
animals really are not working
or not working well enough when we take
them into humans so there's a huge false
discovery rate
coming out of animal work into humans
and we call this problem
the translation crisis
so often at this point in a talk people
think that i'm crazy
so just to give you some some lovely
examples
the first is a review both of these
reviews are from 2010 um
of uh of the current state of play and
alzheimer's
research so this first review is looking
at
all published studies um of the
genetically modified mouse model of
alzheimer's npp
knocking mouse and
of over 200 plus studies um of
uh i think over a hundred compounds for
our own correctly
um none have been replicated in in
translational human studies
in fact several of those human studies
actually had to be ended early
because of unexpected side effects
so that's that's a zero percent success
rate
in the case of stroke this is a very
famous example
and in fact um uh this team
in particular emily cena has done
several follow-up studies um looking at
stroke
um but again 500 plus studies reporting
effective treatment for ischemic stroke
in animal models
only two of which translated to humans
and one of which we already knew about
before the animal work was done so in
fact only one of which actually
translated forward from animals to
humans
so that's pretty terrifying um
but we can begin to sort of plug these
numbers
into um into some economic and process
models of the pipeline
that are out there and um and we can
begin to think about how many projects
we might need to
um to launch in order to actually
get a drug to market that's going to
help people
so using the numbers that i've shown you
when we plug in our real world
worst case scenario with a 10
reproducibility and a three percent
translation rate
um the overall success rate um is less
than
um than one percent obviously it's about
point one percent
and in fact we would have on average
have to launch 947
projects in order to get one success
now uh bearing in mind that that three
percent
is cancer and most cancer studies
involve a decent number of animals with
with category e procedures um
as an i cook member and i wish we could
all sort of hold up our hands and
and and interact a little bit here but
normally when i ask an audience
how comfortable do you feel about those
category procedures knowing that
you have roughly a one in 950
then 950 chance that this is gonna
make it through to humans a lot of
people could begin to feel quite
squeamish
and i think that's justifiable
um if we plug in some sort of average
numbers
um that we can get again after the debt
out of the available literature
with a 30 reproducibility rate an 11
translation rate
then we're in a much better state um in
that case
we need about 86 projects before we're
going to
on average get a success and um
if we plug in our current
best numbers which is a 50
reproducibility rate
a 20 translation rate um then we are
seeing
uh that we would only need to launch on
average 28
uh projects per successful um
translation into
the human clinic so i really think it's
important to talk through these numbers
because um i've definitely heard people
claim that
that the reproducibility and translation
crises aren't real or that they're being
made up or blown out of proportion by
animal rights organizations
and that's simply not true and i would
really caution
anybody here who who thinks that that's
a good argument but it's not because
these numbers are very easy to look up
it takes a very very quick lipstick
search on google to find the numbers you
need to
to recreate this table
so um i did have a wonderful animation
of beaker here
this was meant to make everybody chuckle
at home and again i can't hear you so i
don't know if it works or not
but the real key message i think that uh
dr gaskell and i want to get to you
today is that this current
panic is unwarranted um there's a lot of
people running around with a hair on
fire freaking out that
um animal research is in fundamental
jeopardy um
and so on and so forth and that's
essentially not not true
we actually know what makes for a
reputable study
and we actually have a very good idea
what makes for a translatable study too
and we have ways of testing and
demonstrating these ideas
and um and so the real issue here
is is yes there's a crisis in terms of
what is successfully translating and
what is successfully being reproduced
but um it's more a crisis of culture
and and changing um changing hearts and
minds it's not it's not a crisis of not
knowing what to do
it's not something fundamentally broken
with science um
and uh that is really what we're going
to talk about today
so let's put some yardsticks on this
what is the highest success rate that we
can expect
well if we had perfect reproducibility
which is probably impossible
and we had perfect translation so if
every experiment was reproducible and
every compound
that enters the the um the
pipeline only fails um for other reasons
but
every compound that enters actually
works in humans and then we'd still have
only a 68 translation rate that's the
best translation rate we can expect
given all of the other issues
in the pipeline and that would lead us
to
launching maybe four projects on average
per success
so that's our yar stick um
and actually if we plug in some
reasonable numbers
so if we if we plug in 80
reproducibility
and an 80 efficacy rate then we're at
seven projects for success
and i i don't know where you where you
fall but
um honestly anywhere from that
reasonable seven percent
um seven projects per success to 28
projects for success
in that case i'm you know if the science
is good
and and everything is being done to to
maximize the welfare of the animals
involved
then as an eye cook member i would be
okay with a category procedure
so again i i really don't think that
that this is this is sort of a nail in
the coffin of biomedical research or
anything like that
but it is something that i think we can
improve and it is something that
that i think we owe science and public
health and animals
um to to improve and i'll explain why in
a second
so where did i get these 80 numbers from
well if you remember
we are supposed to power our experiments
the way we consent and as
um briana is going to run run through
power is the chance that if a result is
there that you'll detect it
and that sort of directly translates to
uh
to reproducibility circuit powering at
80 we should have an 80
reproducibility rate on average and um
i think we can also apply that logic to
efficacy like if this
compound really does work there should
be about an 80 percent chance that we
can get it to work in humans
and that's that's where i i get that 80
percent and 80 percent from
there so always explain your assumptions
because they're usually
questionable
so the the general failure of of
compounds
um to make it through the pipeline is
referred to as attrition
and um attrition has been well
uh discussed in in the drug development
literature for a very very long time
uh this is beautiful work from um paul
and colleagues
and this is the best economic model of
the pipeline that i'm aware of
um from from this model we know that of
the roughly 2
billion dollars it costs to bring a drug
to market
um roughly 75 of that cost
is the cost of all of the other
compounds that are going to fail um in
the pipeline
in that company um whilst that success
has been developed
um but only three percent of this cost
is in pre-clinical work so in other
words almost all of the cost of drug
development
is in the failure of human trials
and um and
this this leads to many of these sort of
perceived societal ills
of of the farmer industry and i think
it's really really important to
understand this
if you are are sinking this enormous
amount of investment for a
relatively low rate of return you can't
afford
to make drugs for people who um
who don't seek help or rare conditions
or acute conditions
um and once you begin to to work through
all of the different things that make an
indication um
profitable then um it really does begin
to explain
um a lot a lot of the sort of
development biases that you see within
the industry
and that's just economics it's not it's
not it's not any kind of um
uh malfeasance but it is why for
instance
you know we we have um we have these
huge healthcare disparities
uh in terms of the availability of drugs
for different indications
and i'm happy to talk through some
examples of that
in questions if it's of interest to
people so this is why i think this is
also a public health crisis i think if
we can fix this problem
then we can begin to develop drugs for
underserved communities and
and i work with a lot of underserved
disorders so that's an issue close to my
heart um
we can focus more on women's health
which is a really important consequence
of parts of
this issue we can afford to develop
drugs for populations that maybe can't
afford to pay for them
um drugs like anti-malarial for instance
anyway if we try and superimpose on this
pipeline
the extent and invasiveness of animal
use um
these are very very hard numbers to
estimate but um
i think we can probably agree that the
majority
of the really invasive animal use is
occurring in pre-clinical toxicology
um and
given that attrition may be unavoidable
unavoidable right we we may always have
that same total failure rate
um a lot of people in the drug industry
have basically argued let's try and
move this attrition into pre-clinical
stages where it really doesn't cost
anything
um in other words let's try and fail
fast fail early
and fail offer and i love this idea
because if we can do this prior to
pre-clinical work
then everybody wins right so um
we're we're we're avoiding the business
cost
um we're about avoiding the welfare cost
and
um all of that uh increased efficiency
in terms of
time effort and financial resources can
be poured into some of these broader
public health issues that i mentioned
so that's really what we're trying to
get to um as our long-term
outcome so how do we get there well it
turns out that
um there's been a sort of explosion of
emerging literature since the
the mid to late 2000s and this is just a
small
fraction of some of those papers and
what's really fascinating about this
emerging literature
is that um it even though most of these
people
didn't know each other when they were
writing these papers they're incredibly
consistent in what they're saying
so it doesn't matter whether somebody's
writing about stroke or about cancer or
um or whatever the indication might be
all of these papers in one way or
another
value that there's an inherent argument
that there's inherent value to animal
work
that the translation and reproducibility
are unacceptably low
and the way to fix the problem is to
make a change in perspective where we
focus on what we've chosen to ignore as
a consequence of what we've chosen to
control so right now
we're all about reporting what we've
controlled we're all about controlling
everything we possibly can
but in fact that is the fundamental root
of the problem in many cases
and secondly that maybe we need to start
viewing animals as patients
not tools and in many areas there is
also a feeling that we need to act now
before it's too late
before we lose too much credibility
and so if you're interested in this um
and
in 2017 we we try to sort of collect
together this literature and put our
arms around it and pull out some common
themes
um and uh this paper uh
basically argues that what we're seeing
here is a paradigm shift a really
fundamental
change in the way in which people are
beginning to do biomedical research
and um and we work through some um some
questions you can ask yourself
to try and improve your reproducibility
and translation
but of these the easiest uh um the most
immediately implementable and most
proven solution
is experimental design statistics and
just to illustrate that
um uh it's really nice to look at glenn
begley's work so glenn beckley
um was involved with onboarding
compounds out of academia
into um a drug company
and and this is in cancer and
so his his lab basically took a compound
they re
they tried to reproduce the the really
exciting result that had been published
by the academics and um and on the basis
of that decided whether or not they were
going to bring
the compound into the pipeline and
amazingly he reported about a 10 success
rate
what was even cooler about his work
though was that
um because of the access that they had
to the original research he was able to
go back and look at the original
research and try and pick out features
which predicted
whether or not a academic result would
tran would
successfully reproduce when he brought
it into the company
and it turns out that there are six
questions he could ask and if the answer
all of these was yes then
pretty much a a compound would would
transl
would sorry be reproducible um in in his
hands
and um
the first of those is where experiments
blinded rihanna's going to talk about
this in more detail
but just to give you an idea um kilkenny
and colleagues recently
surveyed um top papers in
top journals of biomedical research and
the rates for this are shockingly low
right so
14 on average of of experiments are
actually blinded
13 were probably randomized again
something brianna's going to talk about
and um and bias avoid it
and i mean i'll just be perfectly honest
like if i was grading an undergraduate
research project and they didn't blind
and they didn't randomize
i would send them away and get them to
do it again
if they had time this would be
unacceptable
and it really is unacceptable in
published work
another really simple question that he
asked was were the right kind of
statistical tests
um used and again um uh dr castle's
going to work through this in a little
bit detail
um but we have some good ideas on that
um
nature medicine for instance um 2005 had
a statistician just flick through every
paper
um in a year's worth of the journal 38
of them
um used appropriate statistical tests
uh this new house paper i love um
and it's looking uh for a very
particular but very common
um statistical mistake again which um
we're going to talk through
later on um which is
failing to use interactions in in in
factorial designs when that's that the
hypothesis under test
he looked through the top five journals
in neuroscience um
found that 50 of behavioral neuroscience
papers failed to analyze these kinds of
experiments properly
and not one molecular neuroscience paper
um did and that's again a year's worth
of papers
out of the top five neuroscience so
again this is just simply unacceptable
like
this this this should be being caught by
reviewers it should be being caught by
iron
it's just not okay and in fact
when we look at all of his six questions
were experiments blinded
and biased avoided were experiments
repeated are all the data presented
are the positive and negative controls
with the right tests to use
five out of six of these are just basic
experimental design and statistics
and so the simplest thing we can do
is we can go to glenbard's paper which
is you know only a
couple of pages it's a really nice read
um
and we can ask that about every protocol
that we look at
um and i've written a couple reviews
sort of expanding on this a little bit
um but right now i'm gonna hand over to
dr gaskell who's going to talk you
through
how in practice you can
think through some of these issues and
apply them in your own research and also
look for them whilst you're reviewing
papers or reviewing protocols so thank
you very much for your attention
um i'll be back for the q a and i'll
hand it over to my
esteemed and wonderful colleague dr
brianna caskel
thanks joe um so obviously joe's
set a really good example of like what
the big picture is why
we're talking about these types of
things with the second half of this
presentation we're really hoping to give
you some practical
ideas to take back to the lab and some
of these are things that i work through
with my graduate students
all the time and so and and are some
things that i notice that working with
industry
that i see over and over again and some
little small
things that can easily be fixed in terms
of statistics experimental design and
how you're setting up that experiment
that can easily be fixed in order to
really help with these
reproducibility issues
so so before we get started
a lot of what i'm going to be talking
about is power
and sample size and like joe said
power is the change that assuming there
actually
is a real world effect that your
experiment will actually detect it
so we want to make sure that the work
that we're doing is actually worthwhile
now power is actually a function of
signal to noise ratio and i
felt like this image really helped
represent that that if you have a lot of
background noise going on
it's really hard for you to detect what
that signal is
and so a lot of what people do
is attempt to increase their sample size
in order to
increase the signal another thing that a
lot of people don't realize is that
that increase in the signal um reduces
the noise but these two things at
different rates and so this can
be a little bit challenging um in just
that being the simple
assumption that if you didn't have
enough power you just increase the
sample size
and so what we're hoping that by doing
that what people are thinking is that
you'll really be
able to amplify that signal reduce that
background noise and really be able to
detect
the the question or test that we're
trying to do to really find the true
answer
and so we can actually reduce noise
through increasing the sample size but
it it stabilizes fairly quickly
and really the only way to a certain
degree and the only way for us to really
further decrease that that noise is
really through
good experimental design so in actuality
um any signal will actually become
significant
if you have a big enough sample size but
this could actually require
thousands to hundreds of thousands of
data points or animals
and so really what it comes down to is
finding that result really worth those
animal lives
and is this something that's really
going to be
translated well into into human use
so what happens is that when people
increase sample size this is really a
brute force approach
and it's not a sophisticated enough
idea but that really if we want to
reduce that
that overall noise we really need to be
utilizing those sophisticated
experimental designs
and having a much more strategic and
smart approach to how we're actually
going to be
running these experiments and really
hope to reduce that noise
and see our signal in the end so
what joe and i have done for all of you
is to make up a data set
it's completely fictional based on a
generic experimental design and so what
we're going to do is we're actually
going to go through together
and talk about different aspects of this
experiment how we might actually
analyze it in different ways and what
kind of outcomes we can get
based simply on same data same
fictional animals um but that
we can get different results depending
on how you analyze the data
so for our fictional experiment we're
going to have two different main
treatments we have some experimental
drug that we're interested in and of
course we're smart experimenters
we're going to have some type of control
group or a placebo
so we would be injecting our animals
with one of these two things but
again we're very smart and we're paying
attention to the literature and some of
the other
speakers um in this labyrinth session
are going to be talking about the
importance of adding both sexes
so hopefully you are already doing this
but
we're pretty smart too we've listened to
those talks
we're going to include both of the sexes
in each of our groups
to make sure that we don't see any
interactions that might be different
depending on the sex that the drug is
being provided to so what we're going to
do
and one of the things that i want to run
through with all of you here because
this is going to become
important later on when we're going
through some calculations
don't worry they won't be too hard is to
really
focus on and make sure that people
understand the difference between
when somebody reports a big n or a
little n in
how many animals they may have used so
when somebody reports a big
n this is basically the total number of
animals that were used
in the experiment so in our particular
example here
we have a big n of 80 because we're
adding up all of the animals across
these four different groups
and that's where we get 80 a big n of
80.
now if somebody reports a little n of 20
this actually means that in the smallest
combination
of our drug and sex in a factorial
design
so in each of these four groups of drug
by sex
we have 20 replications or 20 animals in
this case
that is the smallest combination
and so make sure that you understand
that when you are reporting in your
manuscripts or reports or whatever that
might be
that you understand the difference
between big n and little n because that
can make a really big difference
and you'll see how it's important to
understand the difference as we work
through some of these examples
so we have our data set we're going to
start off with
probably something that all of you who
have ever taken any kind of statistical
class workshop they probably walk
through
a t-test and this is actually something
that we're recommending people not do
but this is usually the first thing that
people feel comfortable with
and so with the t-test we're only going
to be testing our treatment variable
so i've got a i've run that t-test of
our main effect of drugs so it's looking
at the difference between
our drug group as well as our placebo
group and you can see that our
probability our p-value
is not statistically significant it's
0.12
so we didn't find a difference between
our two groups
based on the main effect of drug now
something that you want to pay attention
to
is your r squared because this basically
tells us
how much variation in our data our
outcome variable
where we are actually able to explain
with our model
so our model in this particular example
is just the main effect of drug
and we were only able to explain about
three percent of the variation in that
data
that's pretty bad so okay
well that didn't go as well as we would
have liked
and we did not reach significance which
in essence means that you did not reach
significant enough power
and so well what if we had wanted to
achieve 80
how many animals would we have actually
needed in order to reach that 80 percent
power
well you can't actually solve for power
post talk that's kind of a no-no
but we can actually estimate the number
of animals that we would have needed in
order to
reach that level and then it comes to
kind of a
an ethical question does the
if we wanted to repeat the study with
more animals
would that number really justify the use
of animals
and so i went in and i calculated
estimated the power based on
the parameters in this data set and we
find
that we would have needed between 260
and 280 animals in order to achieve that
80
power that joe was talking about that is
a lot of animals
potentially almost 200 more animals
and i think a lot of us would think that
that was probably not
worth those animals lives in order to
achieve that power
all right so that didn't work out um
so next we're going to try a two-way
anova
and so we designed this into our
experiment so
of course we would want to include the
main effect of sex
because this is something that we were
interested in in the first place so of
course we'd want to include this in here
so even though we included it we still
don't are not finding statistical
significance in either of these two
main effects so that's not going great
still either
we look at our r squared and it is
increased
slightly but it's still not very good
this is pretty poor
explanation of that variability simply
due to these two factors
again if we wanted to achieve 80 percent
how many animals would we have needed
and again really doesn't change much we
would have needed between 260 and 280
animals
so the t-test and the two-way anova
really aren't
giving us that much power so we'll move
on to
the next level of experimental designs
and this is called a split plot design
now don't worry i'm going to walk you
through this it's actually a pretty
relatively commonly used experimental
design
that was traditionally used in
agriculture so when you say split plot
it pretty much was used for different
plots of
growing plants and the thing that's
really great about split plot designs
is that it helps us deal with real world
issues
let's say that you have a factor that
you want to study but you can't change
it
as easily as other factors and so
it allows us to kind of work with that
so if we have this
general plot of land that we need to
test some fertilizers and different
types of seeds for
let's say corn i'm in indiana we're
probably growing corn
so we have this plot that we're going to
be experimenting with
but one of the things that we need to
keep in mind is that not every area of
the plot
is experiencing the elements in the same
way for some reason
on the top of this plot that particular
area just gets a lot more sun
and at the very bottom of the plot it's
a lot more
uh high moisture content in the soil
and so the top receives more sun the
bottom receives more
water content and so if we want to test
some fertilizers
which we can only apply to large
sections of land
and we want to try and do this entire
study in in one
growing season because you know
temperature varies from year to year
and so we want to see how all of these
elements can affect
these fertilizers and combinations with
different types of seeds
so what we need to do is start splitting
up this plot into different types of
subplots and like i said we can only put
fertilizer on large
portions of our plot so we could set up
our fertilizers with fertilizer a
at the top and fertilizer b at the
bottom of the plot
but obviously we're confounding some
issues here
we won't know if fertilizer a shows
amazing corn growth if that was due to
high amounts of sun or low water content
or if fertilizer bee works then it's
simply due to low sun and high moisture
content
and so we actually can't tell pull these
two things apart and tell
what might actually be causing the
increases in this corn growth
so we'd probably prefer to set up our
plots more like this
so that both fertilizers experience high
sun
and high moisture content and we have
some nice variation
between these two so the next thing we
would want to do
is then create some subplots within
these two
sections of fertilizer that we'll be
growing and this is where we'll
put in our different seed varieties so
we have four different seed varieties
that we're going to try
and what we would do is we would take a
random number generator i'm a big fan of
random.org
because uh the random number generator
in excel is not a true random number
generator
um that we would use a random number
generator to figure out which seeds go
in which plot
so i did a random number generator and
we see this order of seeds
we would use this random number
generator again to figure out the order
of the seeds that go in fertilizer b
subplots but of course we'd want to use
that but we would also want to balance
across these different subplots we would
want to make sure
that you know seed three didn't always
go in the outermost
sections or the innermost sections so we
would want to balance across
these different subplots so that's all
well and good
we can figure out how to plant and test
different types of seeds and fertilizers
in indiana
but what exactly how can we apply that
to our example experimental design
and what we can do is that if we're
looking at this we can identify
we need to figure out what that large
subplot would be
and so if we're looking at our two main
treatments our drug
as well as looking at different sexes
which of these two things
can we not change as easily as the other
well most likely that's going to be sex
we can't really change that and assign
that to animals
based on a random number generator so
really what we're going to be doing
is we're going to become going to be
separating our two subplots kind of like
we showed in the
agricultural example that we'll have
males and we'll have females
and then what we plan to do so this is
our top layer our between
subject layer and so what we're doing is
we
are in which the effect we're looking at
the effect of our drug
um of being male uh how it's tested and
how we can see differences between
males and females and between subject
and between subject
so these smaller subplots are actually
our cages
so we have 20 cages for males and 20
cages of females
and we're going to put two mice in each
cage
so we'll have one drugged mouse and one
placebo mouse
now one of the things we also want to
make sure
that we account for is that
we want to blind ourselves so it would
probably be best
that i might have a colleague
pull up the syringes of either drug or
placebo
in order in an animal order in a cage
order for me
so that i actually don't know what i'm
injecting these animals with
so this is one type of blinding that we
would probably want to
initiate here in our sophisticated
design
so not only that but we'd also want to
balance from cage to cage
which animal actually got the injection
first and whether that was a placebo or
a drug
so let's just assume that the first
animal out of the cage
has less time to be stressed due to um
being scruffed but the second animal due
to that delay of opening the cage
may actually experience more stress
simply because they're sitting there
waiting they know that something's about
ready to happen
and so we would want that balanced
across both of our
both of our different types of drugs so
i set this up just to kind of
make that connection back to those plots
that we
were talking about from the the corn
example but this is actually not how we
would want to
set up these cages on a rack
we would actually want to use more of
this checkerboard example
where we would go oscillate between
males and females we already have both
drugs being represented within each of
these subplots
and so maybe we would split these up
between rack one and rack two
or perhaps they're on the same rack and
on various sides
but one of the things that i run into
quite
often is that um i come into a vivarium
and i see
that animals sexes are willy-nilly
assigned to a row or column and so you
can see that if we were looking at our
males and females here
this is not really achieving that
checkerboard
design so we might want to do something
a little bit more like this where we're
again we're oscillating back and forth
between male and female
but one of the things that we really
want to focus on and and how this is
really like
our plots um that i was explaining with
the um the corn example
is that let's say this top row um
similar to our plot might be
experiencing more sun well obviously in
the laboratory
we're not actually experiencing sunlight
but this top row
may be experiencing higher light
conditions which has actually been shown
to cause stress
and affect drug disease progression
in different types of disease models and
so
we obviously wouldn't want to put all of
our treatments on the top row because of
that
essence of the top row receiving more
sun
on top of that the top row might be
experiencing more vibration simply due
to those blowers and motors on the top
of the rack
and that might vary as you go lower on
the rack on the lower rows
not only that but we're interested in uh
the columns
as well so this particular column as you
can see in this image
is closer to the activity that's
probably going on in a daily basis in
the room
people moving things around people
running studies and we actually know
from the literature that in other
animals that
proximity to the door can actually cause
more stress
than um if the animals aren't as close
to the door
so it's possible that these animals in
this first column may
be experiencing more stress simply due
to the activity that might be going on
in the room closest to the door
than the animals that are closest to the
wall so that's why we're looking at both
our columns and our rows and how those
things might be affecting
the animals similar to how the water and
the sun was affecting our growth of our
corn
in our plot so we figured out our
split plot design we're going to
now include cage as our subplot
and actually this becomes a blocking
factor for anything
any variability that falls within that
cage so it could be light intensity it
could be vibration
the thing that's beautiful about this is
that we don't really care we don't have
to know what that is
as long as we can control for how the
mice that are
in that cage are more similar than the
animals and in another cage
so we include this blocking factor and
the way that we kind of indicate that
we're doing a split plot design
is by incr including a cage
factor in our analysis but we're also
going to nest
that within sex and so this is what that
looks like in a model
and basically what we're saying is that
this cage can only belong to one sex
and so which makes a lot of sense it's
an all-male cage or it's an all-female
cage and so this is how we indicate it
in the analysis
so let's go through what did we find
we've got some statistical significance
on cage
which actually we don't really care
about but it's telling us that there's a
lot of variation from cage to cage in
our experiment
um and between cages within a sex
so this could indicate variability that
falls on that cage level
so again the animals on the top of the
rack may be experiencing things that are
different than animals on the bottom of
the rack
and we can see that from our r squared
we have jumped
from three percent with our two-way
anova to 96
of the variability this is humongous
in terms of the improvement in this
statistical analysis
so if we go back and we look at that
power actually we probably could have
gotten away with even fewer animals
um than the 80 that we tested perhaps
somewhere around
40ish animals um and that we could have
achieved uh
80 power between 44 and 48 animals
so we could have gotten away with a lot
less animals in this experiment
but we're not done yet so we have
sex in this design and we have drug in
this design
well most likely the reason we have both
of those factors is that we're curious
about
how those two things interact so we want
to include an interaction of sex with
our drug effect
so again we're just adding this
interaction of drug by sex which you can
see at the bottom there
you can see that we're actually
improving our
uh statistical significance with sex now
being
significant our r squared well we can
see that in general
that um we are seeing differences
between males and females
and that uh really it's an effect of
females so perhaps there's something to
do with how the drug interacts with
estrogen within the body
that affects the outcome whatever that
is that we're testing
that now we would know that it doesn't
really have an effect in males but it
really does in females
and so if we look back at our r squared
it's increased from 96
to 98 so a small increase but still
fantastic
so in terms of our power again we would
have needed between 44
and 48 animals in order to achieve 80
power and remember we've used 80 animals
in this experiment so we're still way
overpowered
so how should we have actually
calculated our sample size
so we've already run the experiment but
how should we have started this entire
process
well calculating power for factorial
designs which is what we did here
is actually really complicated and you
can't use you cannot
use i need to stress that you cannot use
a traditional power calculation
that is designed for running t-tests
and we're not running a test test we're
super smart experimenters and we are
going to be using some of these
sophisticated split plot designs and so
well how do we do that if we can't use a
traditional power calculation
well there's something called meads
resource equation
and it utilizes a curve of diminishing
returns
that basically shows that as you add
more animals you
receive less and less power as you add
more animals
and essentially what we're doing with
this equation is calculating the number
of degrees of freedom for your f
test so for your model as well as your
error
and really what we're looking for here
the really important part is that the
error term needs to be between
10 and 20 degrees of freedom now this is
my
favorite little thing that i think i've
come up with in the last few years is
that
um joe and i just published something
indicating that we should be using the
prices right rule
when estimating our error degrees of
freedom
and basically what this is is that you
want to design an experiment
that brings you as close to 20 without
actually going over
because once after you get over 20
degrees of freedom in your error term
adding more animals really does not
provide you
with much additional power so you
receive a lot of power
up to about 20 but once you go over that
it's not really
providing you with much benefit so we
want to find our error term between 10
and 20.
so if any of you remember if you're
calculating your anova tables
basically you're calculating the number
of degrees of freedom in your model
plus what's left over your error term
and that will actually give you
the total amount of degrees of freedom
in your experiment
well we're interested in error and so we
need to solve for error so we're going
to use our
fancy schmancy algebraic
information and we're going to kind of
rework this so that we're
actually solving for the error degrees
of freedom because that's what we're
looking for
we want that to between 10 and 20.
so with our experimental uh
equation here with our mead's resource
equation and kind of running through
our practice example here we're going to
go through and calculate each of these
things so don't worry i'm not going to
leave you hanging if you can't remember
how to
calculate degrees of freedom so the
first thing we're going to do is we're
going to calculate that total degrees of
freedom
well that's actually really easy so it's
the total number of data points that
you're using in that
experiment for this particular example
we have 80
data points because we have 80 mice and
so you take 80 minus 1
so your total degrees of freedom is 79.
so next we'll calculate the degrees of
freedom for our model
so we know we're going to be doing that
split plot design so how many degrees of
freedom would that cage blocking factor
require well this has to do with the
number of cages that we have in the
experiment remember we had 80 mice
we had two mice per cage so we have 40
cages and we've nested that within sex
and so we have two levels males and
females for that variable sex so it's
simply
40 minus 2 and that gives us 38 degrees
of freedom
the next few are pretty easy we're
looking at sex we have two levels of sex
male and female we minus one that's one
degrees of freedom
similarly with drug two minus one gives
us one degree of freedom
and looking at our interaction this is a
slightly different but we're going to
multiply the degrees of freedom for sex
by the degrees of freedom for drug so
we've already calculated that both of
those are one
so it's simply one times one gives us
one degree of freedom for
our interaction so if we add up all of
these
for our model degrees of freedom that's
41 degrees of freedom
so we take 79 minus the 41
so our error term is actually 38 degrees
of freedom
and we are way over that 20.
we should be between 10 and 20 so we are
way overpowered
so we're using more animals than we
actually need okay well that's great so
how would i have calculated this and
figured this out
before i started the study so how are we
doing our a
priori sample size calculations
so our original design we had two
different drugs
two different sexes and we had 20
replications so remember that's our
little
n that i was talking about in the
beginning and that gives us
a big n of 80. so we had 80 animals in
this
original design well let's look at maybe
having that using needs design so we
have two drugs times two sexes but in
this time our little n is going to be 10
and so our big n through this uh
calculation
is going to be 40. so let's go through
and see how this would have worked out
with our error term
so we'll walk through this again for our
total degrees of freedom
so now we have 40 data points we have 40
mice in the experiment
so our total degrees of freedom is 39
for our model the number of cages
remember we're putting two mice per cage
so we have 20 cages
minus that two levels for sex so that
results in
18 degrees of freedom simple with the
sex
two minus one is one simple with the
drug two minus one is one
and then our interaction again really
simple degrees of freedom sex
times degrees of freedom drug equals one
so our total degrees of freedom was 39
we minus the 21
and our error term is 18. so this is
perfect
our error degrees is as close as we can
get
to 20 without going over so this is
probably
a good design using for a factorial for
our split plot
so let's actually go in and look at the
analysis
so what we did we used the same data set
that i've been using in all these other
calculations i just randomly chose
20 cages because remember the first set
we had
40 and the last set that we cut
everything in half we're going to have
20 cages
so i just blocked those off and did not
use those in the analysis
and we can see that even with half as
many animals
we still find statistical significance
and have a very
high r squared so we're really able to
identify
that variability in our data in our
outcome measure
based on what we're testing in our model
and actually
we possibly could have gotten away with
fewer animals so this is looking at the
power
for just our main effect of drug and
it's actually saying that we could have
gotten away with even fewer animals
perhaps around 26 um
and still achieved 80 80 uh 80
power for this experiment so
we reached significance with 40 fewer
mice that is an
amazing reduction so thinking about how
we're implementing the 3rs
reduction in our animal use that's
that's amazing
so that's really exciting we can use
this as experimental design
and so we kind of wanted to leave you
guys with some
things to look for things to think about
as you're
designing your experiments and looking
at experimental designs
um that kind of go back to some of these
pitfalls to watch out for
so the first of which is compounding
treatment with cage
so we might want to reduce animal
numbers per cage so remember
um one of the biggest effects that
really shot up
our r squared was including that
blocking factor of cage
and so we could run this experiment with
groups of mice and four
so our drug uh group at the top and our
or our placebo group at the top and our
drug group in the bottom
but maybe if we actually increase the
number of cages
and reduce the number of animals we
could actually improve
that power by being able to subdivide
that variability from cage to cage
the next thing that we could do is we
could split treatments across cage
so i've got our our experiment here
we've got um
our drug animals and our placebo animals
but we have one treatment in each cage
so it would be a better design actually
if we could
apply the treatments both treatments
within one cage
so we'd have both drugged and placebo
animals actually very similar to
the experimental design we just went
through here
next we want to make sure that you're
not confounding treatment with rack
position
and this is where you utilize a latin
square now don't worry about that
it basically means you need to do some
cage sudoku
so this is actually a game that i love
and maybe why
i love doing this part of experiment
design and so basically if
you don't know what sudoku is you get
this table and you have to fill in these
empty squares
with um the numbers one through nine now
the numbers one through nine
have to go on a row but they can't
overlap with the numbers that go in the
column
and they can't overlap with uh each of
these sub-squares our subplots perhaps
and so this is essentially what we're
trying to do on a rack
so if we line up all of our females on
top and all our males on bottom
it's like putting all of our ones one
one one one one
and then all of our nines on the bottom
so this is
not achieving sudoku well what happens
if we go
male female male female well it's the
same kind of thing we have all our ones
on the top
and the next row is all nines and so we
still are our confounding
treatment with um rack position or row
in this instance so again
we have not achieved sudoku
so really what we're looking for is
again that that
um checkerboard effect where we see the
effects
of high light intensity on that top row
between males and females
across our rows and our columns
next is failing to blind so a lot of
times people think of oh of course we
want to blind our data collector
so the person who might actually be
writing down or recording different
types of our
um whatever we're collecting our main
outcome measure
so of course we want to do that but what
a lot of people don't think about is
that we need to make sure that we are
blinding our care staff
as well so perhaps that person who is
providing
those injections making sure they're
blind to the drugs being
injected as well as the people who are
taking care of those animals
if they know that a particular drug is
maybe going to make the animals not feel
so well they might
focus all of their um you know
observations
on or not equally
across all of our cages and treatments
and so they might actually
um bring in veterinary care more often
for the animals that are getting the
drug
so this is something else that a lot of
people don't think about we need to
blind our care staff as well
we can tell them that things are going
on but we don't necessarily want them to
know
who is receiving which treatment and
then last sometimes you can't actually
completely blind i do a lot of research
where we implement an enrichment
which obviously you can't blind yourself
to you can see it in the cage
and so what we can do is we can actually
blind people to our hypothesis what do
we actually think is going to happen
and so if you can't completely blind
yourself you can at least blind people
to what your hypothesis
is and this is the reason why
blinding is so important because uh we
see that
um in a study a systematic review run um
by mccann and all in 2016
that they found that if you were not
blinded your effect size or the strength
of your of the uh thing that you're
testing
was significantly higher if you were not
blinded
so this is showing us that even though
it's not
malicious in what we're trying or um
we're trying to
fake our data but subconsciously we're
making
slight alterations in perhaps some of
these outcome measures that's
skewing the overall true effect size
next we want to make sure that you're
analyzing interactions properly
so in our experiment we were curious
about how drug would affect our sexes
differently
so obviously we want to make sure that
we actually include that interaction in
the analysis
so we wouldn't want to do just the plain
split plot but we would want to include
that sex by drug interaction in order to
see how males and females differed
to receiving that drug
so this is essentially what we would
want to include
next we would want to watch out for
anything justified by a t-test so if
you're sitting on an ayakook
and you're looking at someone's numbers
gender justification
you really generally don't have enough
information in order to
determine whether this was done
appropriately or not because we never
at least in my experience i don't see
people asking for
the overall experimental design or even
asking for an example analysis
how are you planning to actually what
statistical tests do you plan on using
and so this is something that i think i
cook should include
in a lot of those proposals so that you
can accurately determine whether
somebody did
a sample size calculation correctly or
not
and last pitfall do not do
pilot experiments for numbers
justifications
so what we find in the literature is
that in general pilots use
very small studies very few animals
which
leads to it being underpowered which if
they do find a significant effect
it's generally going to be an
overestimation of the effect size of
that particular treatment
which if somebody moves on to do a
full-scale experiment
their likelihood of failing is really
high
and in the end we've wasted all of these
animals
so we highly recommend not using pilot
experiments for numbers justifications
but simply use mead's resource equation
and just
do the experiment
so with that hopefully we've left you
with some practical tips and tricks
of how to easily implement some small
changes in order to
improve your experimental design improve
your statistics and hopefully
help with this reproducibility and
translation crisis
so thank you to all of the lab roots
organizers
joe and i have some additional
information if you're interested in some
of the work that we're doing
down below here and we wanted to point
you to um two of these papers he's
already mentioned the ethereal
epistemology paper
but a lot of the things that i just
talked about and the topics that joe
talked about were in this power to the
people paper
that was uh published at in jlass in
january of this year so if you want more
information more in-depth explanation
you can find some of that there
and with that i think we are ready for
some questions
hey hi everyone so thank you dr garner
and dr
gaskell for a very interesting and
impactful presentation
like dr gaskell just said we will now
start the live q a portion of the
webinar
just as a reminder if anybody has
questions you'd like to ask
please do so now just click on the ask a
question box
located on the far left of your screen
and we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for
um so i've got one question here
um from virginia
and she asks is there a way to do a
randomized
out the cage is very labor intensive to
have more than one treatment group in
one cage
besides a concern about possible
treatment error
do you want to take that joe or you want
me to yeah uh
so when brianna was um was was talking
and and this question popped up i i
highlighted it
uh strangely
this is a question that i tend to get
asked almost exclusive but
exclusively by cancer researchers um
and my understanding at least from from
many of my colleagues in cancer research
that i've talked to
is that it is very very usual to have
five mice in the cage on one treatment
five mice in another occasion another
treatment five mice and occasionally the
treatment
and that's a pretty standard
experimental design in the field
um the fundamental problem there is that
say you're looking at up four treatments
and you have five mice in every cage
people think that their n is 20.
it's not it's one because you have no
way of knowing
whether your treatment effect is due to
the cage or due
to the drug that you were giving to all
of the animals in the cage
and um so the simple answer to that
question
is yes it may be more work for the
experimenter
but as briana showed
with that with that example data we went
from needing 260 animals to find the
drug effect
to needing less than 20. and so
the the time saving the money saving the
the animal
lives that are saved the the um
the sunk investment cost that's saved
because
instead of thinking there's not an
effect there you actually find it all of
those savings are worth
the extra effort of of thinking this
stuff through
and it is not hard if you're going to
gavage every animal in a cage
it is not hard to gavage one with one
compound and another with
with another um if you're going to do
injections similarly you've got to
inject every mice
like just do it we um we have a paper
that we're
writing up right now where i had a grad
student
doing exactly this with estrogen
injections
versus vehicle injection and
and yes it was a lot of work but
we did it and it
really broke open the um the work that
we were doing there that led us to like
a major major discovery
and and especially in
behavior work but also especially in
cancer we really know that the cage is
incredibly important that the cage
you're in
is actually probably the single largest
source of noise in your experiment
and her practice data set that was
really evident
that that is the biggest factor that we
real that a lot of people are not taking
into consideration
and so i understand your hesitance to
uh change up how you're doing some of
the in setting up these experiments but
like joe
said this could potentially lead to you
not needing nearly as many animals or
nearly as many cages
and so it may come out in the wash in
terms of time investment
by using some of these more
sophisticated designs and
applying your treatments across cage or
within a cage
so i think it's one of those things that
it might be worth
trying out and you know the first time
you do it if it's kind of
a cluster try it again because the more
you get used to it
the easier it is and so that's one of
the things that i recommend is that if
you do it once
and it just feels so flustered because
you're trying something new and so this
is something that i see
a lot of groups doing um when i've
worked with fac
with folks in industry is that they put
all treatments on one
one row and they don't stratigraph
strategize across
um treatments within one cage and so i
think it's something that's worth trying
and um even if it feels fluffy the first
time please try it again
and so so having having been a bit
pedantic and i think
in terms of just going no this is just
the right thing to do
there are absolutely situations where
it's not possible so for instance um we
were doing some experiments where we
were
administering drugs in the water and in
that case in that case you are
administrating
drug at the cage level and so
in that case um you can think of the
cage as being nested
both within sex and drug
and in that case the the smart thing to
do
is to have as many cages as possible
right with
two animals per cage is a much better
design if you have to
apply the treatment at the cage level
and
a lot of the time though you can still
get into this sort of split plot
situation so imagine you're applying the
drug at the tree at the cage level
but um you're really interested in
you know your you think it's targeting a
particular receptor
so you're going to have a knockout and a
wild-type mouse
in each cage now right and because you
would expect the drug to work in the
wild
type but because it doesn't have the
receptors to bind to it's maybe not
going to work in the knockout
and so so sometimes
i totally agree it is just a lot easier
to apply treatments at the cage level
but again you can you can get at these
powerful designs by maybe then varying
something else in the cage which doesn't
require
the same level of handling and effort
and you know honestly i think if we
if we think about it that sort of drug
by genotype um experimental design is
actually one of the most common
experimental designs we see in
in in biomedical research and and again
that's very easily done by applying the
drug at the cage level
having two different genotypes in the
cage and then you get back to
essentially exactly the same
analysis we're talking about and of
course you can layer sex on top of that
and you and you should
okay moving on to another question
this is from andrew
should we focus should we instead focus
our energy on replacement techniques
eg human tissue models to solve the
problems of translatability
and reproducibility can you address that
in brief
um
i'll start and you can chime in um
so i think that that's a good idea in
order to
see if we can start moving some of these
replacements forward but
you know all of the hot topics with the
human on a chip
type replacements that are coming
through these are really exciting but
the problem is is
we really can't use them yet and so
understanding and even with those humans
on a chip
they still don't encompass the
complexity and the mental state of the
animal
so one of the things that we um we
really can't replicate
and for good or for bad is that you know
animals may be experiencing stress
due to aspects in their environment and
that stress
is altering that overall mechanism of
whatever you're trying to study and so
we can't
model that on a chip and so i think that
there
is some benefit of moving some of these
replacements forward
and i will be happy as a clam
being completely out of a job not being
able to do anything with animal
experimentation i will
do a happy dance on that day but i
really don't think that that is going to
actually happen in my lifetime so i
think there's some benefits of moving
some of those replacements forward
but i don't think they completely model
everything that we're trying to get at
and the whole animal experience that
cannot really be replicated in a
replacement anything else
yeah so um i have two things to add to
that uh
first of all just to really emphasize
the point that brie made
um we know in many of the diseases we
really care about so neurodegenerative
diseases
um cancer hiv
we know that in humans the single
biggest predictor
of survival and and and
and recovery is the quality of your
social network
and um so for instance in in one year um
survival and breast cancer
the quality of the social network and
the largest study of its kind ever
reduces your risk of death 50-fold
that's far greater than than most of the
compounds we're interested in in cancer
right
and um so this is actually an active
area of research in my lab
is is what is the underlying mechanism
of these social support phenomena
because they happen in animals too
you can do exactly the same thing in
both rat and mouse models and in cancer
but actually social housing really
changes the underlying physiology of the
animals
and um and so
you would never get at that in an in
vitro experiment so
number one this integrated physiology
point that we made is is just incredibly
important
and um the second is that actually if
you dig around in the literature you're
going to find
plenty of um of people talking about
lack of reproducibility and in vitro
experiments as well
off the top of my head i couldn't tell
you what those rates are um
i was actually having a quick look
whilst bree was talking and i couldn't
find any really good numbers
um but in our own experience for
instance
we see that that there is enormous
variability
from 196 well plate to another right
so if you're doing molecular work you
really need to make sure
that you have an equal number of case
and control samples
on or treatment samples whatever it
might be
on your on each 96 well plate if you're
having to use multiple for an assay
and you should include the 96 well plate
as a blocking factor in your in your
analysis and in doing that
we've been able to again using this r
squared number the proportion of
variants explained
go from very very poor r squareds and
to really really high r squareds because
actually the thing that everybody thinks
is is incredibly reliable because it
comes out of a machine that
goes ping and automatically gives you a
number just has an enormous amount of
variance in it
so all of all of what we're talking
about here applies to to molecular
assays and like you're working in vitro
work as well
great thank you um uh hopefully a little
bit
simpler one maybe um from julie evans at
nectar
she asks are you concerned with hormone
changes
handling both males and females and it's
not
why
yes bree i think this is more up your
alley
ria are you muted
yes i was starting to rain and thunder
here so i thought i'd minimize
the background noise um so uh
i think so what i was saying was that i
personally have not had
issues with this i know a lot of people
are mostly worried
about handling males and females back
and forth simply due to
pheromones getting on their gloves and
then it causing
all of this aggression afterwards um
that's actually not something that we
have experienced in my lab not saying it
doesn't exist
but um definitely pheromonal
chemical communication is a huge factor
um that these guys are paying attention
to that we
just have no idea what they're
experiencing and one of the things
we're actually studying some of this at
least chemical communication
but within a sex so we're looking at
chemical communication
within aggression in mice and trying to
figure out
we know a lot about what instigates
aggression
pheromonally but are there any things
uh chemical wise that can reduce
aggression
but um at least from going back and
forth from sexes
i've not experienced that but um
it's probably still something to be
cautious about
um but i i think it's more of an
issue of not setting up these
experimental designs in
in the right ways um that is going to
have a bigger effect
than just handling males and females
back and forth
i've done that a lot myself and not run
into any issues
but like i said um it doesn't mean it
doesn't exist i've just not had any
experience with that
um another question from
[Music]
lord ventura at abby is can
you
so um the short answer there is again
i if i understand this question
correctly it's like can i put all of my
mails on one rack and all of my females
on another
and then the answer is no because you
don't know whether the effect is due to
sex or it's due to rack so
again that's what you've got to really
think about right when you when you're
designing an experiment
have i accidentally confounded something
i'm interested
in was something
really uninteresting
to that sudoku example is that um
you know i was confounding location on
the rack with
um with sex in a few of those examples
and so really want to get to that
sudoku all of your treatment groups um
across row in each column to make sure
that if you have an effect due to
light intensity or location in the room
or whatever it might be it's equally
distributed
across all of your different treatment
groups
so i would agree no it's not what you
should be doing
okay um another question
um i've marked a couple of okay there's
a couple of the popped up that i think
are really
important can i jump in on one yeah go
for it
sorry i don't mean to um so we we have
one here
um has there been any sort of analysis
to show that
using any of these parameters or changes
in experimental design truly has an
effect on reproducibility and that is
from
david uh yes
again very very short answer there um
are some beautiful large data set
um retrospective studies especially
coming from people like malcolm mcleod
and emily cena
where they've looked for patterns in the
literature um
myself and hannah verbal have set up
sort of like fake labs
and and shown that this kind of stuff
works and then there's a
really large um study that came out
recently
across multiple labs uh which involved
hanoverball and emily cena
where that they took this to the next
level and again showed that
reproducibility is massively increased
if you just
adopt some of these small changes um so
yes there's a there's a
very strong evidence base for for the
stuff that we're talking about today
sorry that that is it's i i
the reason i picked that one out guys is
um
i think a lot of the time a lot of the
people in these sorts of meetings were
almost like preaching to the choir
and and people want to do what's right
and they they
they kind of already are ready to make
these changes and the real question is
how do i persuade the pis
um and in in
part of my role here where i do
do stats consulting for four pis and for
the i cook at stanford
um there is nothing like showing
somebody that they can do the same
experiment with five or ten times
less animals and what they thought was a
pilot experiment
was actually already an overpowered
publishable piece of work
right when people see the amount of time
and money you're going to save them with
decent experimental design
they're almost always instant converts
there's always some people
who will hold out but 90 of the time if
you can show them
how it hits their bottom line which is
time and money
for academics and an industry it's time
and
and money and and success rates um
then people are quite easy to win over
and i think that also answers another
question which we have here which is
it sounds like we need a cultural shift
i totally agree
um the the thing that i see and i think
um both um brianna and megan comments on
this too
is that that cultural shift is already
happening in pharma
um when i when i go and work um
and consult within pharma i generally
see people already beginning to think
this way
um i'm very eager to implement these
things
where it's not happening is in academia
right now at least in the us
and and that's why i think um the
iacooks are incredibly important and i
will really emphasize this because one
of the things i've noticed is that
the further you get away from a
veterinary issue right and i cook is
perfectly happy to tell a pi
oh we this algae zero regime is not okay
you have to change your experiment or
your your surgical technique here is
gonna be problematic you have to do it a
different way
we're totally happy with that we're
totally happy telling
an experimenter we don't care the nih
review group
signed off on this you're still using
the wrong anaesthetic and we're going to
make you use the right one
we're totally happy doing that well
if you actually go and read the oh lord
guidelines chapter and verse
the i cook is empowered to to make
any change like that on any aspect of
the experiment
and there's actually a question in the
old fact
when we asked questions um isn't icook
allowed
to impose changes in experimental design
and the answer is unequivocally yes
so seeing as you know
and and this again hits other questions
like improved aseptic technique
improve anesthesia those are refinements
improved experimental design
is reducing animal numbers and actually
you can also think of it as being
a soft replacement right and and russell
and birch actually
and if you for those of us who who read
it they talk about improved experimental
design
where you're reducing animal numbers
actually as being a form of soft
replacement
thanks to you guys well um i think not
only that but
um aya cooks feeling like they have the
power to make suggestions like that but
at least with my experience is that
a lot of times the ayaka doesn't feel
comfortable
making statistical suggestions
whatsoever they just don't feel
because every single field does things
slightly differently
and they don't feel like they have
enough knowledge
and they assume that the pi has
sufficient
knowledge to know what kind of
experimental design they should be
utilizing and i actually see a comment
down here
from uh from someone at lead in
university
and they said well that's why you need a
statistician or methodologist on your
iacook team and that is exactly what i
usually recommend
because you need somebody on there who
has the strong
background of information and
understanding about how these things can
be
so altering in the number of animals
that we're using
and ultimately the number of animals
that like joe is talking about
potentially going through some of these
you know category e types of experiments
and being ethically okay with that
and making sure that we have strongly
justified
why you need that many animals and i
really think that that is
a really great addition that i'm seeing
more and more aya cooks
uh invite statisticians onto
their boards because i think it can do a
lot of good
and so one thing i would add to that
is um sorry i'm sorry um one thing i
would add to that is that
um really what we're trying to do here
is to raise some red flags
and and when i do i cook trainings on on
numbers and experimental design
that's that's exactly what i do right
it's like i don't expect the i cook to
become experts in experimental design
but if you can just look for a few of
these red flags and when you see them
have a pet statistician and and by the
way the best kind of statistician
is is at the risk of blowing my own
trumpet
somebody like me who was a biologist
first
and uh and a statistician second because
a lot of the time the people who are
pure statisticians they don't understand
like the details of the way the assays
work or the way that the metal
or or the underlying biology and things
like that actually really do influence
how you would want to analyze the
experiment
um so if you can find like
you know a pet biologist who does a lot
of stats or pet psychologists who does a
lot of stats and
and wrote them into uriah cook um
that that's also a really really good
way of of doing this
and um and by the way ecologists field
ecologists tend to use a lot of these
sorts of techniques
um psychologists tend to use a lot of
these kinds of techniques
so even if you can't find somebody in
your stats department who's willing to
help
you you can sort of dig around and say
oh who's who's teaching the um
the you know statistics for psychology
course because every psychology degree
program
has a has a compulsory um
statistics component and maybe that
person would be the person you want to
go to
yeah agreed
okay we have a few more minutes
uh joe and brianna are there any key
questions that you guys see that you
want to answer
or shall i just pick one for you just
pick one
okay um
so meeting of them do you want me to do
one of the high ones
sure okay so one of the
um high priority questions is for
um any experiment should we use both
male and female animals in the same
group
or should we use only one of them at a
time lots of lots of sex questions
today um well
you should definitely do them at the
same time
so generally when i am working with my
graduate students
um megan can attest to this hopefully um
that i make them think of all of the
combinations of all of their treatments
whether
whether that's the drug whether that's
the sex whether that's
something else that we're interested in
maybe we're looking at different types
of mice or rats
we want to run all of those things at
the same time
because what you find is that maybe when
you first start off the experiment
you have a heat you know a heat wave
and the air conditioners go out and so
the temperature in the room goes up
and then you know later on it gets fixed
and then people are over
over cooling the building in order to
try to make up for this
so are there all of these small little
environmental factors that can
affect the overall outcome measure
and so what i what we want is we want
all of
our treatment groups so our drug by sex
interactions to all be affected by these
environmental runs so
even though you can't run let's say all
of those 80 mice at the same time
but you can look at smaller runs over
multiple replications of those in order
to
make sure that whatever those
environmental influences are they're
affecting
all of your treatment groups at the same
time so i would
highly highly recommend that you're
running both sexes at the same time
great i will do i
think one more um so from
uh virginia at
the ohio university um
cheeks of the person doing the
experiment um
per jeff mogle study where he saw
differences
yeah that's that's that's an awesome
question so
um jeff mogul by the way if you guys
don't know him is
is a really fantastic researcher and i
strongly recommend
um if anybody's interested in this stuff
you sort of read back um
he has an amazing paper with an old
student of his um
called chesla where they went through
eight years
of data in the lab and they simply asked
i'm sorry for the background noise they
simply asked um
what predicts pain respond they're
looking at tail flick
and the single biggest influence
was the identity of the experimenter and
this
fundamentally i think this is such a
good question to end on because this
boils down to everything that we're
saying mice live in a different world
from us
right they're crepuscular they live in a
world of touch
and smell they can see colors we can't
see they hear sounds we can't hear
there is no way that you can possibly
control
everything that matters to a mouse and
it doesn't matter
if you have in red mice that are saying
you know like c-57 black six mice
are selling bred their clones but in
multiple examples
we see that the higher up the rack you
go the more stressed out they are
that stress affects their hpa axis and
that affects their immunology
um we've shown that this is an effect on
abnormal behavior we've shown that this
is an effect
in aggression there's beautiful work in
not mice and type 1 diabetes
where again you see that right the mice
on the top of the rack
are so stressed out that they're immune
suppressed and it takes much longer to
develop type 1 diabetes
so the whole point of this idea of
blocking
is that we don't know why the blocks are
different
we just know that they probably are
and and that's the beauty of this
blocking and nesting thing right
is that is that we don't have to know
why this cage is different from this
cage we just have to know that the
animals in this cage are more similar to
each other
than the animals in this cage and
and if you don't
actually have a cage effect which in
mice i refuse to believe
but if you if you don't actually have
one because of the way all of this math
works
introducing a block doesn't
change the power of your experiment if
it is an
unimportant and so if cage has no effect
it doesn't change any of the math all of
the f ratios stay the same
so you lose nothing by including it and
even if it has a small effect one that's
not actually
significant as but you would never look
at the p-value of the block anyway that
doesn't make sense but um as long as it
has some effect it's going to make your
experiment stronger
and so the question here was should we
worry about male versus feminine
experimenters
yes that's one of the reasons why
experimenters are different
um this beautiful work from the 60s but
i don't know why people did this
but they looked at the effects of cat
feces on
fear responses in mice and rats
and if i recall this experiment
correctly and
i may be remembering this wrong so tell
me if i'm wrong oh my god
um they had cats
fed regular cat food cats fed mice and
cats on a vegetarian diet
and the mice were more afraid of afraid
of the cat poo
from mice fed my cat's fed mice
over cats on a meat diet over cats on a
vegetarian diet
so probably what you ate the night
before
affects how the animals respond to you
and and
all of these things can't be controlled
so all you can do
is balance them across your treatments
that's the whole idea here and and
so whilst we said avoid confounding if
you care
you have to avoid confounding the reason
why cage is so powerful is that
everything that we think is important to
mice sort of clusters on cage right
it's position in the wrong it's position
on the rack these animals may well have
that come from the same litter
they're being handled in the same order
in the day like
like i once made a list of this and came
up with about 20 things that cluster on
cage
which mattered to mice so if you have
something like
the sex of the mouse or sorry the sexy
uh
experimenter all different technicians
working different times of day
as long as you make it consistent and
let it cluster on cage
and you include cage in your analysis
you don't have to worry about it
basically
and and the time that the time the
effort that it takes to think these
things through which is a lot
pays off so much um you spend much less
time thinking about this stuff and
making sure it's controlled for and
balanced
then you do than the saving in the
number of animals that you need in the
amount of time that you need the amount
of money you need to do that experiment
um and now of course there's a whole
bunch of new real questions coming in
um so person interested in ammonia
um then um uh charlie burn
at um at the royal college in london she
actually has a really active um
project here on cleaning compounds and
her impact on mouse behavior and welfare
so i would lock her up
well we will go ahead and wrap up the
section the question section i will say
that
um we still have all the questions that
were not able to be answered
at this time and we can give our our
presenters will attempt to
answer these and reply to them um per
the contact information you provided on
the on-demand
period or or during registration
and so they will do their best to try to
still answer your questions
um i really
school for the work and then i just like
to open up the floor to them
if they have any further closing remarks
for the audience
i think the the big thing that we've hit
home multiple times in the questions as
well as the presentation is really
looking for
those pitfalls so looking at
when you're evaluating your own
experimental design or if you're an ayat
cook
trying to determine whether somebody has
done a proper numbers justification
really keeping an eye out on those
pitfalls and
in order to help you identify whether um
you know somebody you need to ask more
questions or you need
further justification so that would be
what i would leave the group with
anything further joe yeah my my
two red flags and is
one if somebody has figured
power using t-tests or the power of
calculations for testing correlations or
regressions
that's actually a red flag because then
we know that they're not actually
blocking their experiment
so it's it's really cruel and unfair
on the on the researchers actually right
but the
the only methods for which you can
calculate power ahead of time are the
methods you shouldn't be using
which is why we really emphasized um the
mass means um
mass balance equation so that um
that is something that that when you see
those kinds of power justifications
that probably actually is a red flag and
the other thing that is a huge red flag
for me is
is pilots experiments which which bree
touched on um
the but just to re reemphasize that
point is if you are underpowered
and you get a significant result that's
actually
because by accident you saw a larger
result than what's true in the world
and so if you then say okay this is what
i expect my difference to be
you're actually going to underestimate
the number of animals you need and your
follow-up experiment is unlikely to be
successful
so that so um
for reasons that it's not really worth
discussing just as as a statistical fact
if you say i'm going to accept p equals
0.05 as being significant
and you get p equals 0.05 your power is
exactly 50
so if you have a non-significant result
you
post-hoc power is meaningless um your
postdoc power will
be insufficient and if you have a
significant result then your postdoc
power will be super high
we actually saw that in some of the
slides that we showed you so
when people are wanting to do pilot
experiments
yes you can have technical pilots i
don't know how to do this injection
i don't know if this method of imaging
is going to work that needs one or two
animals
but pilot experiments to estimate effect
sizes
are are just fundamentally misguided and
um
there's a beautiful um paper by by uh
button and
that who's in john io anders's group
that really explains this very very
nicely
and is one of the many papers that we
reference actually in in in the
in the papers that are accompanying this
uh the review papers that are
accompanying this
so if you see something based on t-test
it probably needs to be redesigned if
somebody wants to do a
pilot experiment to estimate sample size
that's actually deeply problematic and i
know that's probably breaking a lot of
brains right now but it is a very
important point
awesome well thank you both again uh dr
carter and dasper gaskel
to all the uh participants for attending
and for your
i hope you all are able to watch more of
the presentations today
have a great day everyone bye